Sex scenes can be very awkward and not just
for actors, but for the audience too.
These pivotal moments can make or break a
movie.
And because the subject matter is so personal,
it’s hard to know how the scene will be
received.
But, we can all agree that there are some
scenes you just don’t want to watch in the
company of family.
Here are 10 Movie Scenes You Never Want To
Watch With Your Parents.
American Pie
Talking about the birds and the bees is a
rite of passage, but when your dad is Eugene
Levy, it can be a downright disaster.
American Pie is a teen comedy specifically
about sex, right down to its title.
After being told by a friend that doing the
deed is just like “warm apple pie” Jason
Biggs’ character takes the description literally.
If you’re mortified by the idea of talking
to your parents about sex, imagine one of
them walking in on you humping a pie.
With too many cringe-worthy moments to count,
it’s safe to say that American Pie is best
viewed in the company of friends instead of
relatives.
The 40 Year Old Virgin
From his role as Michael Scott on t.v’s
The Office, to big-screen features, Steve
Carrell is the master of awkward interactions.
So masterful, in fact, that it feels like
The 40 Year Old Virgin was the role he was
born to play.
After some friends find out that he’s never
had sex, he kicks things into high gear and
starts looking for some lady love.
Director Judd Apatow and Carell co-wrote the
story, so it should go without saying that
The 40 Year Old Virgin isn’t traditional
family fare.
The slew of innuendo alone is enough to send
most parents running for the hills.
8 Mile
The Curtis Hanson-directed 8 Mile follows
the story of a budding rapper trying to break
in to the Detroit scene.
The film’s protagonist Jimmy, played by
Eminem, struggles through an unenjoyable day
job, only to come home to an abusive and chaotic
family.
Along the way, Jimmy meets Alex (Brittany
Murphy) and his luck starts to turn around,
and the two have a romantic rendezvous.
The performance might not have been 100% fake
either, as the actors were involved with each
other behind the scenes.
Coupled with Hanson’s shaky-cam, this display
is guaranteed to make any audience member
feel like a fly on the wall.
The Notebook
Rachel McAdams and Ryan Gosling are the pride
of Canada, and in 2004 the rest of the world
got to understand why.
The Notebook is a love story for the ages,
and tells of Allie and Noah: two kids from
opposite sides of the tracks.
It’s hard to believe the two actors didn’t
get along at first, considering their natural
energy on-screen.
After settling their differences, Gosling
and McAdams pulled off one of the most iconic
and romantic sex scenes of all time.
Too bad it was cut short.
Apparently censors thought the original cut
of the scene was too graphic, and threatened
to pull the movie’s PG-13 rating.
Requiem for a Dream
Easily one of the most intense movies ever
made, 2000’s Requiem for a Dream isn’t
exactly the kind of movie you watch on family
fun night.
The Darren Aronofsky-directed film takes a
no holds barred look at the perils of drug
use.
As the story unfolds, the characters fall
deeper into their addictions and take drastic
measures to secure their next fix.
Based on the 1978 Hubert Selby Jr. book of
the same name, Aronofsky leaves nothing to
the imagination.
And while the movie is very highly rated,
it’s probably best to watch this one on
your own.
Black Swan
Ballet is serious business, and in 2010, Black
Swan director Darren Aronofsky showed audiences
the darker side of dance.
Natalie Portman took home an Oscar for her
portrayal of Nina- a ballerina in distress.
Throughout the movie, Portman wrestles to
keep her grasp on reality as she descends
into madness.
Her dark-side counterpart, Lily- played by
Mila Kunis- takes Nina out on the town to
dance their demons away.
And their night ends with some fervidity.
Or does it?
Audiences are split on wether or not the passionate
affair was reality, or a construct of Nina’s
escalating delusions.
Blue Valentine
Part of what makes 2010’s Blue Valentine
resonate so strongly with audiences is it’s
raw depiction of the depths of love.
It’s one of those movies that you’re happy
you watched, but never want to sit through
again.
Ryan Gosling and Michelle Williams are perfectly
paired as a married couple whose relationship
slowly erodes over time.
The film has a few risqué scenes, each showing
a different stage in their relationship.
One scene from the beginning of their relationship
depicts oral sex, and was apparently too real
for some critics.
Nobody looks perfect during the act, and Hollywood
has a habit of glossing over a lot of aspects
of sex.
But Blue Valentine avoids all clichés, and
reminds viewers that you don’t have to be
Ryan Gosling to have sex like Ryan Gosling.
Fifty Shades of Grey
We’re not arguing that Fifty Shades of Grey
is a good movie, but we can’t deny that
it’s a steamy one.
The film takes a look at a young woman’s
raunchy journey into the private world of
billionaire Christian Grey.
Based on the book of the same name, the movie
was controversial.
Director Sam Taylor Johnson and author E.L.
James’ depiction of BDSM has sparked conversation
around the culture of sexual consent.
And has some people asking where artistic
liberty ends, and real-life consequences begin.
With a whole story revolving around sex, it’s
not a surprise that 50 Shades was met with
such mixed enthusiasm.
Sure, your mom may have this book on her bookshelf,
but that doesn’t mean you want to bond over
it.
Superbad
Superbad follows the story of virgins Seth
(Jonah Hill) and Evan (Michael Cera) as they
attempt to navigate high school.
Parties, booze, and sex are all on the menu…
sort of.
At one point, Evan has the opportunity to
get down with his crush Becca (Martha MacIsaac)
at a party, but their drunkenness gets in
the way.
The two are on completely different wavelengths,
neither one listening to the other.
The on screen clumsiness is nothing compared
to what you’ll feel as it unfolds.
The only thing that could make it more painful?
Watching it with your parents.
Ahh young love.
The Wolf of Wall Street
Margot Robbie’s star has been rising steadily
over the past few years, and fans can’t
wait to see her take on Harley Quinn in the
upcoming Suicide Squad.
Audience members might remember her as Naomi
Lapaglia in 2013’s The Wolf of Wall Street.
The Martin Scorsese film chronicles the life
of Jordan Belfort (Leonardo DiCaprio), a stock
broker with the world at his fingertips.
One thing he can’t always have though, is
Naomi.
Who knows how to manipulate him.
The actress was fully committed to the role,
and insisted on staying true to the character.
Even after being covered in paper cuts thanks
to a scene where the two get down on top of
a pile of money.
Ouch.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite steamy moments?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more videos like this one.